antoine on l'a vu de nombreux dirigeants
appellent ces derniers jours un cessez
le feu a commencé par emmanuel macron
vladimir poutine pour l'instant son
succès alors où en est la diplomatie oui
déjà quasiment deux semaines de conflit
pour l'instant pas l'ombre d'une trêve à
l'horizon pourtant dans les coulisses la
diplomatie s'active aujourd'hui à genève
avait lieu vous l'avez évoqué une
rencontre entre les représentants du
groupe de minsk
soit la france la russie et les
etats-unis et le ministre azerbaïdjanais
des affaires étrangères alors cette
réunion se tenait à huis clos et pour
l'instant rien n'a transpiré mais la
position de bakou est bien connue seul
un retrait des forces indépendantistes
arménienne pourrait mettre fin aux
hostilités à moscou aussi ça bouge
vladimir poutine s'entretient
régulièrement au téléphone avec le
premier ministre arménien et lundi c'est
le ministre arménien des affaires
étrangères qui est attendu dans la
capitale russe écouter you 11 au 13
octobre 2020 le ministre arménien des
affaires étrangères aura mnatsakanian
envisage de se rendre en visite
officielle à moscou le ministère russe
des affaires étrangères accueillera des
négociations entre les deux ministres au
cours desquelles sergueï lavrov et son
homologue arménien évoqueront les
problèmes internationaux et les
questions de sécurité régionale
bien évidemment l'accent sera mis sur la
situation extrêmement difficile dans la
zone de conflit du haut karabagh la
russie tant à titre national que dans le
cadre du groupe de minsk de l'ouest se
déploie constamment tous les efforts
possibles afin d'obtenir un
cessez-le-feu immédiat est de réunir les
conditions nécessaires à la reprise des
négociations
on le voit la diplomatie est à l'oeuvre
que ce soit à genève aujourd'hui ou
encore à moscou en début de semaine
prochaine
d'ailleurs le kremlin n'écarte pas la
possibilité d'organiser à terme une
rencontre trilatérale même si ce n'est
pas d'actualité pour le moment
avec l'espoir que le dialogue entre les
nations parviennent à une issue concrète
avec comme première étape indispensable
la conclusion d'un cessez-le-feu dans le
haut karabakh
merci anthony claireaux pour ce
décryptage en direct donc
de moscou en russie